là c'est du WAV ski et là c'est quand on
est allé au montsmichel donc av r bike
là c'est petite partie de karting et là
c'est parachute dans parapente ici une
vie palpitante au-delà du handicap sport
sorti entre amis ou travail Caroline
fruchot savoure chaque instant de son
existence en mai 2018 cette versaillaise
est victime d'un accident de ski à tigne
et devient paraplégique une lésion de la
moelle épinière entraînant une paralysie
des deux membres inférieurs hospitalisé
du 8 mois à Garche la jeune femme de 30
ans peut compter sur la présence
indéfectible de ses proches le fait de
les revoir de savoir qu'ils étaient
toujours là d'avoir leur soutien bah ça
m'a aussi énormément porté Lefin avec ma
famille mes amis tout l'entourage qui
était aussi présent et en réalité je me
suis battu pour moi mais je je me suis
aussi battu pour eux suite à son
accident Caroline met un terme à sa
carrière de pâtissière elle monte sa
propre entreprise et crée hostobox en
2021 une boîte boî garni de gâteau de
jeux ou de soins du corps un concept
inspiré des colis surprises qu'elle
recevait de sa famille durant son
hospitalisation l'idée avec hostobox en
fait c'est vraiment d'essayer d'égayer
le quotidien des personnes qui sont
hospitalisées de permettre en fait à des
proches qui veulent avoir une petite
attention pour leur pour la personne
qu'elles vont voir à l'hôpital que ça
soit autre chose qu'un bouquet de fleurs
ou qu'une tablette de chocolat et voilà
la
bête toujours passé à l'été 2021 elle se
lance avec sa sœur dans un périple d'une
dizaine de jours entre versaill et le
monts-michel 400 km sur ce vélo à la
seule force des bras un défi sportif
pour donner un autre regard sur le
handicap toutes les personnes en fait
qu'on rencontré c'était vraiment de les
de les sensibilisé de pouvoir leur
montrer que quand on est en fauteil
roulant et ben en fait la vie elle est
pas terminée et qu'on peut quand même
toujours faire des choses dans notre
quotidien et qu'il est aussi hyper riche
voire peut-être même plus riche pour
certaines personnes que des personnes
valid on va dire à l'avenir Caroline
aimerait parcourir le tour de la Corse à
vélo ou descendre la Vallée Blanche à
ski dans le massif du Mont-Blanc des
projet plein la tête pour montrer la
voie et prouver que le handicap n'est
pas une
barrière